of your 365 tips
which is one or two that you have the
most trouble following
yourself that's tricky that's tricky
tricky tricky let's find out well okay
self-fulfilling prophecy tip number ten
that one my sister again my sister's
psychologist gets on me all the
time and stuff um can i actually just
read it or no sure please do
all right it actually starts with my
little sister psychologist see she's the
one who inspired the
tip number ten self-fulfilling prophecy
my little sister is a psychologist
she loves to warn me against
self-fulfilling prophecies
what's that basically if you think
something will happen
it might happen but if you think
something won't happen
it definitely won't happen keeping a
positive attitude keeps you in a better
mood and ensures you're working towards
staying that way
but if you think negatively believe
you're going to fail
you will fail because you'll get it in
your head that you're going to fail
and you'll subconsciously keep yourself
in the failing mindset
making it nearly impossible to succeed
don't get yourself into a negative
self-fulfilling prophecy
don't tweet it don't say it don't even
think it stay positive
that is one i definitely have trouble
with because i'm
wanting to get meetings for these
awesome new shows coming out but
nobody's returning phone calls
or and so i'm like oh this is never
gonna especially when you're getting on
twitter and and facebook and you're
friends with people who already are
professional writers
you're hearing about all the cool shows
they're getting meetings for
or you're hearing about them having like
a sale meeting next week with abc to
sell their show to them
or they just got this really cool
assignment through crypt tv
to write a horror series for them that's
all so daunting when you're
trying to do it and not doing it so
vaughn i start saying oh
i'm never going to get there because i
haven't gotten there yet
now i'm keeping myself in that mindset
i'm never gonna get there
and and keep failing and failing failing
whereas if i keep
that's fantastic for them i'm gonna get
there really soon
you might actually get there really soon
now because now you're striving towards
it whereas as soon as i get the
depression of
i'm never going to get there well right
because now i'm going to stop doing
working as hard because
what's the point anymore right so that's
definitely a pitfall that i
have a problem with and she will tell
you that's absolutely true we just had
this conversation last night
so that's one issue and that's a really
good one yeah that was the first one
that came to mind about that
um let's see turn off facebook is tip 54
procrastination much yes i do
um
let's see those are probably the two big
ones i have a problem with
okay those are good oh female
descriptions
i definitely accidentally at least on my
first drafts we'll definitely be using
things
talking about like how attractive
someone is and
it's not like stuff that flies anymore
especially when you're doing it only
with female characters and not with guys
like why is all your female characters
attractive females
but all your men are just who they are
you know
it seems a lot um i'll even this one's a
short ones i'll even read this one for
you
beautiful gorgeous stunning sexy a
knockout
the kind of girl that is so hot that
would be so hot if she didn't have
makeup
do you see where i'm going with this
using these sorts of statements to
describe your character
is boring and flat and a bit sexist even
if it's not meant to be
but there's no normal girls in your
script they're just all gorgeous pieces
of ass
huh but then the problem is that a lot
of writers will have those descriptors
for the women you know they'll have like
debbie 34 hot blonde or
you know jessica age 26's
an attract would be very attractive
without her glasses or something but
then the men
are dan 54 the kind of guy you don't
want to get in a fight with
how does that tell you what about you
know you're using
looks of the girls but for guys you're
using personality traits why
you know so i i feel like i fall in that
especially in my first
in my early drafts like when i'm doing
like a first draft of the script
because i'm in my head like the first
thing comes in my mind is is
what type of person like what they look
like so i can figure out who who would
play them
because i like to kind of sometimes cast
in my head so i can kind of think of
mannerisms
and and that sort of thing um
so the first thing that comes to my mind
is is what they look like i feel like a
lot of writers probably have that same
issue but the problem is we're only
doing it for the women i'm not i'm not
telling you
how ruggedly handsome bill is you know
so what if it was a writer that was
attracted to bill
whether they were male or female and
they this is what was
visually appealing to them and so if
they were
at a coffee shop and they saw bill walk
by they would be like wow he is ruggedly
handsome
oh my goodness and whoever whoever the
writer's perspective is sure they're
just writing who they find each other i
i think it comes to
not knowing your character well enough
yet because you're
just going on that initial instinct you
know if i see somebody at a party
i can see okay they're attractive or
they look like a freak
or whatever i don't know who they are
yet so i can't tell you oh
this is like somebody that you know
they're very soft-spoken
until you get on something that they're
passionate about because i don't know
that yet i'm just looking at them
so that might be an issue of like you're
writing the script and you're
not quite sure who the person is quite
yet especially not outlining
my but i outlined so my problem is just
that it's i'm going with the visual
first and and
worrying about character in like later
drafts because i'm
you know still telling i'm i know what
they're going to do i just don't know
who they
are yet sort of thing you know so um
so then for someone who's writing a
character that they are attracted
attracted to sure whatever the the
gender um
not focusing so much on looks right
because
especially if you're not doing it across
the board if you're telling every person
what every person looks like
that is one thing it's also going to be
a little boring by telling what every
single person looks like
i hate reading the scripts what they're
wearing there are so many
i've read so many scripts where they
tell me the costume that they're wearing
in every single scene i don't need to
know
were blue jeans here but they were
khakis over here it's not important
it's not story right that's set dressing
and you know and
but so like if you're if you're gonna go
and tell whatever you see even even
using ethnicities i feel like it falls
in the same category you know if you're
gonna tell the ethnicity of every single
character
great but if you're assuming white and
you're just pointing out this person's
black
like that feels racist kind that's true
you know um like
so either across the board tell whoever
tell what everyone looks like
or across the board don't tell us what
everyone looks like and tell us who they
are
got it okay that makes sense i like that
i'm not sure which tip it is but let
people read your stuff
versus don't show your unfinished
manuscript to anyone so i think the
the trick there is the unfinished aspect
everybody and this is another tip that's
in the book that you'll probably hear
frequently is that the first draft of
everything sucks
i don't care how good you are your first
draft is terrible compared to what you
can make it
so if it's unfinished it's already
don't show it to people because they're
going to judge you based on what they've
read
so if the thing is not done yet don't
don't give it to people to put in their
eyes because
if it's not up to par that's all they're
going to see is that you're a sub-par
writer
on the other side though of needing to
show your stuff once it's ready
get it out to the world i've met many
writers who are very precious about
their material
and they won't enter screenplay contests
because they're afraid that people are
going to steal it
which almost never actually happens
there are obviously a couple cases
like the whole thing with the matrix way
back when stuff that oh it was stolen
from i don't know if it's true or not
but there are there have probably been
like a couple of
thieveries along the way but it's very
infrequent because
it would cost the production companies
way less money
to just buy your script than it would to
pay off a lawsuit against them for
stealing stuff
um but if you don't show your stuff out
there either whether it be out of fear
of them stealing it
or out of fear that it's not good enough
you'll never know if it could get sold
anywhere if you if you're like
oh well i don't know if it's good enough
so i don't want to show anyone because
i'm i'm nervous about the quality of it
it might not be good
well then you're never going to know if
it's good enough because nobody has been
able to read it to tell you if it's good
enough
um so it absolutely needs to get out
there but not before it's ready
okay that's good have a laugh every 10
pages
a scare every 10 pages and action every
time sure so this goes with the
genres so that the trick of you know
if it's a comedy if it's supposed to be
a comedy and i'm reading it i'm 50 pages
in and i have not even
smiled probably not funny
um so the trick is to whatever your
genre
is for the script have an element of
that genre
like every 10 pages um that way it keeps
it fresh in your head
oh this is supposed to be scary because
this scary thing just happened here
and now it's happening again um or
comedy oh i just laughed
you know a couple pages ago here's
another joke okay this is clearly the
comedy because if you
stretch out using comedy as the best
example
if you go too long and it's not funny
that's a drama it's not a comedy anymore
um or if if you're writing a drama and
i don't care about anything that's
happening it's just boring
but if it's a horror and nothing scary
happens how is that
how is that a horror at that point you
know it might be a thriller
you know where because there's there's a
fine line going between thriller and
horror
uh but if it's if there's not scary
stuff happening
it's not a because it's not scary
so
yeah so the every 10 pages is basically
just keeping that genre
continuing throughout the whole script
what's your favorite
tip of the 365 my favorite of the 65
uh
i would say let's see if i can find it
here
um
okay so i'm gonna say it's my favorite
because i think it's the one that gives
the most information it's actually
several tips in a row i'm just having a
problem
figuring out where and here it is is
actually about writing will not make you
rich
a lot of people seem to think that oh
i'm gonna sell my script quit my day job
i'm gonna be a screenwriter forever it's
gonna be awesome that's not the case
though
if i can find i think it's like three or
four tips in a row
i can tell you exactly why um but
basically the money that you think
you're gonna make is not
all yours for starters because a got to
think about taxes
you know depending on where you live
you're going to have federal taxes taken
out of it
state taxes taken out of it uh
self-employment tax taken out of it and
city attacks taken out of it depending
on where you live
you're also going to have all the
percentages from your reps taken out of
it so suddenly
you've got like your 100 000 payday and
you're getting like
40 000 left of it that's yours and now
it doesn't look like such a fantastic
payday anymore
you